health is moving I don't think I was
that heavily asleep and it was like oh
is this an earthquake yeah it just
seemed to go on longer than the sep
tember one and then another fence
neighbor ran me up said I hit as a
tsunami warning going are you going to
evacuate and then my husband said all
right what you want to do and I said you
know let's go the information I got was
my neighbor down the road who called me
on this almost mobile that you know he
got her information from her sister
we've got it from facebook myself or my
husband will go to the meeting for sure
there's always information out there
that you need to know how long will they
give us notice wait if signs do go off
and how far inland do we have to go
[Music]